concretamente la casa blanca todavía no
ha emitido el comunicado sobre esta
llamada que duró cerca de dos horas es
la primera llamada que tienen los dos
mandatarios después de la última que
tuvieron en noviembre del año pasado y
el mensaje que sí publicó el gobierno
chino es concreto y es que china no está
interesado en un conflicto en ucrania le
dice a bailén en este comunicado que la
paz y la seguridad es un tesoro
internacional por el que tienen que
trabajar conjuntamente reitero ese punto
reiterando que ya no tiene interés de
tampoco compartir entre
armamento a rusia esto después de la
demanda república públicamente que le
había hecho a vladimir putin sin fin de
ayudarle a rusia en esta invasión en
ucrania esta llamada entonces se da tras
esta demanda y lo que con lo que termina
tranquilizando a muchos analistas es
precisamente esa posición radical y
concreta de parte de china de que no
está interesado en la guerra después de
ese acercamiento tan cercano que tú
vladimir putin consigue un fin de días
previos a la invasión en ucrania es de
resaltar que pues obviamente senadores
se han pronunciado al respecto entre
ellos el demócrata chris murphy que
decía que si china por ejemplo
intervenía en este conflicto las
sanciones económicas a china serían
mucho más severas a ese país que lo que
han sido las sanciones económicas a
rusia